Кожна порція крові, яка надходить
в центр крові, рятує життя.
Порцію крові розподіляють
на три частини,
тому прийнято казати,
що це три врятовані життя.
За шість років — це, насправді,
тисячі й тисячі людей.
«Агенти крові» промотують регулярне,
свідоме та безоплатне
донорство крові в Україні.
Ми спрощуємо процедуру для людей.
Відповідаємо на питання,
супроводжуємо.
Наша мотивація в тому,
щоб зацікавити, змотивувати
донора повертатися.
А підкажіть, якщо донор
на аналіз тромбоцитів?
Нехай проходить.
Ага. Проходьте тоді сюди.
Надихнула власна історія.
Під час Революції Гідності,
це якраз був кінець 2013 року,
я шукала донорів крові для родички,
для маленької дівчинки,
якій потрібно було знайти
десь близько 30 людей,
які мали здати тромбоконцентрат для неї.
І тоді я вперше стикнулася з тим,
наскільки це, насправді,
буває складно і незрозуміло.
Зареєструватися на конкретну дату,
прийти здати кров,
правильно підготуватися.
Я пам'ятаю той час,
коли збирала списки
цих донорів, чоловіків.
І вони мені напередодні дня донації
могли писати в месенджері,
на кшталт: «Так, я іду на Майдан.
Я не знаю, чи вийду
на зв'язок наступного ранку,
тому можеш на мене розраховувати,
а можеш — ні».
І я тоді зрозуміла,
наскільки важливо, насправді,
мати цю базу донорів.
Тоді я вирішила допомагати
в цій ситуації тим,
що буду чергувати в центрах крові.
Я сама не можу бути доноркою,
ніколи не здавала кров,
але я знала цю процедуру
з адміністративного боку.
Я вирішила виступити
такою секретаркою,
адміністраторкою донацій.
З цього все почалося.
Ми почали в серпні 2015 року
з чергувань,
і довгий час вся наша активність
цим і обмежувалась.
Це були чергування в центрах крові.
Щотижневі.
Не довго?
Не боляче?
Ні.
Спочатку чергувала сама,
зробила пост у фейсбуку.
Відреагувала дівчинка, яку тоді ще
я не знала, архітекторка Ксенія.
Потім ще хтось доєднався,
і так, фактично, ми виросли
за шість років так реактивно.
Тобто ми не залучали волонтерів,
вони приходили до нас.
Зараз нас близько 40 людей,
ми ділимося на дві великі групи:
перша група — це чергові.
Крім того, у нас є ще операційна
команда, такий штаб,
який бере на себе якісь
комунікаційні обов'язки,
організовує проєкти.
Зараз ми чергуємо в трьох
центрах крові в Києві,
а також чергуємо в Одесі регулярно.
Також розглядаємо інші міста.
Ми час від часу отримуємо запити
і дуже ними також пишаємося,
тому що людина здавала кров,
а потім вирішила до нас
приєднатися як волонтер.
Мені здається,
що організувати ГО або будь-яку
волонтерську ініціативу, насправді, легко.
Я цього не знала,
але потім, коли наважилася,
реєстрацію, якісь інші процеси можна було
налагодити дуже швидко, насправді,
і це класна новина.
У нас є інші проєкти,
це проєкти з популяризації,
це проєкти разом з бізнесом,
де ми проводимо корпоративні виїзди.
Корпоративні Дні донора — це проєкт,
який ми реалізовуємо разом
з центром крові [Інституту] Амосова.
Інститут Амосова — це велика лікарня,
в якій за рік проходить
більше 7 000 операцій на серці.
Вони мають можливість виїжджати
по компаніях для того,
щоб збирати кров за межами центру.
[російською] Фізичне навантаження
на руку сьогодні скасовується.
Я ж юрист, які фізичні
навантаження, я вас прошу.
Нам важливо зібрати
не менше 20 охочих здати кров.
Це такий ліміт,
після якого [Інститут] Амосова
може виїжджати на донацію.
І потім організовуємо це як свято.
Фактичного що ми робимо?
Додаємо якийсь
комунікаційний елемент,
анкетування, подарунки, банери.
Часом простіше поділитися грошима,
ніж знайти час і віддати
частину своєї крові,
відмовитися від звичайного життя,
три дні навколо цього.
І ми дуже пишаємося тим,
що маємо таких партнерів,
які можуть налаштувати
свою команду на те,
щоб це зробити.
Зробити цей перший крок.
Фактично, після того, як людина здасть кров
вперше й отримає позитивний досвід,
більша ймовірність того,
що вона повернеться.
Тому це дуже важливо.
Щодо підготовки, то тут треба
виконати декілька кроків.
Перший крок — перечитати протипоказання.
Записатися на донацію.
Далі потрібно підготуватися:
буквально кілька днів посидіти на дієті,
не вживати алкоголь,
відмовитися від спортивних
навантажень, від тренувань,
гарно висипатися,
поснідати в день донації
і приїхати на донацію.
Налаштуйтесь на те,
що, можливо, вам потрібно
буде посидіти в черзі.
Це нормально.
Також важливо бути готовими до того,
що ви можете отримати відвід.
Це не каже про те, що у вас
якісь недоліки або ще щось.
Лікар зазвичай пояснює
цю мотивацію,
і потім ви можете повернутися
за якийсь час.
Хто на тромбоцити?
А ви від терапевта вже вийшли?
Так, я записана була.
Я зрозуміла.
А ви пили чай?
Так.
Проходьте тоді сюди.
Після донації безпосередньо
ми даємо подарунки.
Колись ще на початку, 2015 року,
коли це все почалося,
мені просто на фейсбук написала
людина, яку я не знала,
ілюстраторка Даша Горбачова,
з такими словами:
«У тебе класний проєкт,
але тобі бракує якогось подарунка».
Так у нас з'явилася колекція пінів,
вісім клітин крові.
Вони є фактично маскотами
(як в Олімпійських іграх),
талісманами нашого проєкту.
Вони впізнавані.
Люди чіпляють його
на рюкзаки, на одяг,
і тому вже знають,
що вони є також донорами крові.
За кілька років дуже багато людей
зібрало всю колекцію,
і вони хотіли більше.
Ми розширили колекцію бактеріями.
І з'явилися так ще дев'ять бактерій.
Ще у нас є тимчасові татуювання.
[сміється]
[російською] Це один набір, так?
Ми до Дня донора їх робили.
Вони дуже прикольні.
Тут ззаду написано,
як воно все...
Якщо в людини процедура
проходить легко,
вона їй підходить,
дуже класно планувати собі
донацію раз на рік, раз на пів року.
Придумати собі якийсь день уявний.
І просто повертатися,
робити це регулярно,
незалежно від того, чи є якісь
запити в соціальних мережах.
Цим ви дуже допоможете
системі крові, кожному центру крові.
Дивіться, оце головна сторінка.
На ній є три стани.
Перший — ось цей,
тут показані минулі донації.
Основною є кнопка Call to action —
це запланувати свою майбутню донацію.
І виводиться деяка статистика.
Це застосунок «Агентів крові»,
який ми розробляємо разом
з IT-компанією EPAM, EPAM University.
Для чого потрібен
застосунок для донорів?
По-перше, гейміфікація.
Нам треба щось веселе для донорів,
щоб вони витрачали весело час
під час очікування в черзі.
По-друге — інструмент планування
донації на рік вперед,
по-третє — швидша комунікація
з центрами крові.
У світі святкують День донора
14 червня.
Це єдиний день, коли всі
згадують про донорство,
і в «Охматдиті» черга
з журналістів з'являється.
Ми ж вирішили про це
розповідати довше,
і тому організували
конкурс постерів.
Ми отримали 300 різних ідей
і метафор про цю тему.
Крім того, ми провели п'ять перманентних
виставок цих робіт в п'яти центрах крові.
І, насправді, було дуже
цікаво дивитися,
як медперсонал долучався
до цієї виставки.
Вони персонально
відбирали ті роботи,
які вони хотіли повісити
в себе на стінах в центрах.
І, насправді, ця залученість
нас дуже радувала.
Крім того, ми плануємо
повторити проєкт,
який називається «Кров чарівна».
Це проєкт, який ми організовували
разом з [Інститутом] Амосова,
а також із відомими
фотографами України.
Що ми зробили?
Розбили четверги зимових місяців
серед відомих фотографів,
які погодилися прийти і зняти
донорів крові одразу після донації.
Ми вигадали символ цього
проєкту — це гемакон,
ємність, в яку набирається кров,
яка залита не червоною кров'ю,
а фіолетовим глітером.
Так ми хотіли сказати,
що кров, насправді, чарівна,
вона магічна.
Для мене волонтерство в «Агентах крові»
є постійною психологічною допомогою.
Тут реалізується запит на якісь
фізичні, очевидні перемоги,
на які я можу спиратися.
Це реалізація запиту на креативність,
на те, щоб якісь амбіції реалізовувати.
І найбільша цінність,
яку я отримую від
«Агентів крові», — це люди.
Чому важливо розвивати
донорство крові?
Тому що воно про мотивацію
суспільного договору.
Це про те, що ми існуємо
не у вакуумі.
Для того, щоб будувати
сильне суспільство,
мені здається, треба бути готовими
на самопожертву, на допомогу.
Уся система донорства проходить
зараз трансформаційний період.
Треба, щоб створилася екосистема
і достатня кількість донорів,
які згодні ділитися
кров'ю безкоштовно.